[Musique]
359 écoles rurales ont fermé leurs
portes à la rentrée 2010 9
un drame pour certains mais c'est loin
d'être une nouveauté
déjà dans les années 50 certaines
mairies faisait tout pour garder les
enfants dans le bourg quitte à se
transformer en institutrice impôts note
dans la goutte d'or
c'est la secrétaire de mairie qui dans
la classe permet depuis 1950 sert
d'institutrice aux enfants du pays dont
l'école officielle est éloigné de 3 km
avec l'exode rural les villages se
dépeuple de moins en moins d'actifs donc
de moins en moins d'enfants et des
écoles qui ferment pour les écoles
rurales qui survivent c'est souvent le
même dispositif
une classe unique mixte et de différents
niveaux
jean pierre cabanes va assurer
pratiquement non pas une classe unique
de 14 élèves mais cinq ou six cours
différents dont trois élèves
ces écoles rurales sont souvent
considéré comme le poumon du village
certains instituteurs humilité au
contraire pour que ces classes isolé
ferme et que les élèves soient envoyés
dans les écoles des villes il faut qu'il
sorte de l'ambiance dans laquelle ils
vivent
il faut qu'il connaisse autre chose que
le troupeau de vaches
une fois l'émotion il faut qu'il
connaisse autre chose car c'est vraiment
catastrophique pour eux à partir des
années 60 la démographie en chute libre
dans les campagnes impôts de fait le
regroupement scolaire
mais pour certaines mairies pas question
de fermer leur école une expérience est
alors lancé des cours éclaté dans
plusieurs écoles cp dans un village ce1
ce2 dans un autre l'expérience fait
tache d'huile
elle est partout imiter bas la voie
était ouverte
quatre écoles regroupées
conques sillonne actuellement dans le
secteur de vermand malgré ces
expérimentations l'inévitable arrivent
les fermetures d'écoles rurales se
multiplient au grand dam de certains
inspecteurs académiques
il est certain que si l'on se place au
point de vue sentimental il faudrait que
jamais les cobras de 10 parcs
c'est tout de même
même avec l'évolution actuelle des
conditions d'existence le seul dans
beaucoup d'endroits seul centre culturel
de la commune ou monde un village
vecteur de lien social entre habitants
services publics de proximité
certaines écoles rurales font encore de
la résistance aujourd'hui elles
représentent 20 % des établissements
scolaires élémentaires
[Musique]